yes ladies and gentlemen it's finally
here a movie about Nick Fury oh it's too
funny shut up Veronica Fury another
World War 2 movie starring Bradley Pitt
mr. new wrinkles that's what I call him
he's getting a little wrinkly he needs
to work on that first off all
acknowledge that this film has some war
movie cliches like yes war is bad we all
know that by now and like what war turns
a man into I mean what other messages
can you really convey in a war movie I
mainly just care about its character
portrayals and overall execution of the
tale you just hold that thought for a
second can you imagine just having a
tail it'd be pretty cool I wish I had a
tail I'm happy to say fury hits the nail
on the head or whatever the [ __ ]
expression is mr. film is haunting
menacing it's [ __ ] intense same time
it's very like authentic and it does
introduce some like new war jinora type
of feeling to it like they've never made
a battle tank look so [ __ ] cool
before if I was in the army I would want
to be in a tank because I want to feel
like Brad Pitt nobody better predict the
direction David Ayer is fantastic it's
great to see a war film and I don't know
if this is great but it's great to see a
war film that puts you into like the
actual world of feeling like you're part
of this war because you're so invested
in these characters that you feel like
part of the experience for you as well
everyone in this movie is a human being
like a lot of times you watch war movies
and you do become numb to it they just
like body counts just become numbers you
know in this one it's like now these are
human beings like fighting each other
and killing each other and it does make
you question a lot of things about war a
lot of the messages that seem like so
expositional and war movies I felt this
movie you
to actually get those messages across
without being preachy about it like
there are some battle sequences then
yeah they're like really entertaining
but every time a battle sequence is over
it brought it back to like hey now this
is this is really [ __ ] up you don't
want to be a part of this but I would
like to be Brad Pitt for a day I'm just
saying I'm just saying seeing that
picture at Google it you can see his
penis online hung it is awesome too
hairy them it was like 10 years ago
maybe it's changed I mean if you're
looking for a good war entertainment
like you just through the opening it's
like oh that's pretty violent this story
is essentially told from the point of
view of Logan Lerman character who by
the way it's very pretty eyes his eyes
before very pretty very pretty
he's the new recruit for the fury tank
team never been in a war before never
really fired a gun you know I'm trained
to type that kind of dude and like you
know that by the end of this film he's
gonna transform into something else
speaking to transform Shia LaBeouf is in
this movie we'll get to him later
and Logan Lerman does do like a
fantastic job all the qualities of a new
soldier you can like really feel in his
character like the fear the courage the
confusion you know the inner conflict
the thing that makes characters
interesting to watch the themes of this
movie like the questions of war morality
really play into his character you start
to like ask yourself like what would it
feel like to kill someone what would
that turn you into you know well I
already know who I want to kill I have a
long list of people they're mainly
celebrities and I want to kill them out
of love because they don't respond back
to me you [ __ ] [ __ ] it's a very
emotional performance and he is like
100% believable in the role so it looks
like a dick doesn't it but you're
holding it dick like just the whole
ensemble of this team is great because
the film is about their camaraderie like
that's what makes the film so powerful
it's so authentic the way they interact
with each other who these characters are
like you do feel like you're a family
because like when you're living in this
nightmare all you have are your
Brothers in Arms and they are like a
legit family with one Mexican guy he's
adopted Brad Pitt as dawn Dan war daddy
war daddy will calm war daddy that's
what his nickname is the dude blew me
away I can make a [ __ ] joke here but
I'm not going to before watching this I
heard it was like a watered down
performance of his character and
inglourious basterds but in my opinion
I'm like yeah I can see similarities I
guess like technicalities as a full
character like they're totally different
characters he's just a very different
leader
this dude is someone who greatly cares
about like his people there's this great
scene early on where he gives his team
orders and he's you know keeping up his
head straight up and still confident and
then he goes along to smoke a cigarette
and then he starts to like have like an
anxiety attack just in that moment alone
you're like holy [ __ ] this guy is just
he doesn't have it all together
he is also traumatized he is also going
through hell but he's so good to look at
when it's happening it's like war has
become a part of this guy and Brad Pitt
is just amazing in it at times you
question his leadership you question his
motives yet you're like I kind of get it
though most impressive about his
character is that you can see the whole
history of his character just in his
eyes alone those beautiful eyes
God what it would be like to be you for
a day Brad just look into the mirror and
touch myself to the thought of me
touching myself Jon Bernthal as Grady
this dude is ugly in this movie but he's
a really good actor he's like the
animalistic one of the group he's just
like killing machine he's not the most
intelligent he's one of the protagonists
but yet sometimes you're like is he
gonna be a bad guy like you don't really
know and the dude just embodies the role
I hope he gets a Supporting Actor
nomination at least Michael Pena as
Trini
he's the Mexican one of the group what's
great about his role is that he's not
like a comic relief character but
there's such a level of personality and
authenticity to his performance that
does add light to like this really dark
film Shia LaBeouf boy he's like the
badass
yet Christian one of the group he's the
one you know like hey here's some Bible
verses for you same time I kind of got
an attitude problem
now here's what I have to say I didn't
dislike this guy's performance at times
I thought he was fantastic but here's my
impression of his portrayal of this
character
anyway yeah Shia LeBeouf the beauty
always looks like she's crying
I get it war is emotional I understand
but why are you always crying not even
the new kid is always crying Shia
LaBeouf
quit being a [ __ ] ass [ __ ] he still
think you were sexy but something
happened to you man
something happened to you but no overall
he's great let me get straight to the
point here all in all I gotta say
fury got it depressingly surprisingly
war tastic that's [ __ ] up
right oh hey guys um if you guys want to
go ahead and comment below I have a
question if you were to nickname
something fury
what would you nickname I know the
answer for a lot of the responses that
are coming in coming in and last but not
least if you want to get updated every
time one of my reviews or videos is out
go ahead and go to this button and my
dick to subscribe that's right the dick
let me taste something about this little
soldier every time he goes fury on a
woman's vajayjay he soon goes flaccid
because he feels like he's not good
enough satisfying a woman it's one of
the hardest things you can do
don't look at me that way Veronica